yeah i'm i'm thrilled to talk to you
about
uh what your perspective is on what the
heck we are doing wrong
in places like kentucky uh so right now
you have mitch mcconnell
uh in some quarters a deeply unpopular
man
well not just in some quarters deeply
unpopular
in kentucky and i think that's
misunderstood nationally but
definitely deeply unpopular not just you
know in big cities or in the democratic
party but in his state he is
extremely disliked so let's dig into
this because this is a very
is a very important misconception that a
lot of people might have
so i'm just going to speak for myself
outside looking in
mitch mcconnell seems like a a very
uh dc oriented guy he's been there
forever
uh he he he seems eminently unlikable
uh and the impression is that somehow he
has
like this uh mind control over the
people of kentucky
where like like everyone everyone's like
oh mitch she's like
somehow an institution that's what it
looks like from the outside looking in
where you you think
uh that like of course i find him very
unlikable but like you just said that
that
um apparently that's not unique to
people outside of kentucky
yeah one of the things i always get very
frustrated about when i talk to people
from outside of kentucky is they act
like and especially
to be honest with you democrats our side
they act like we're
a bunch of idiots a bunch of dupes who
don't understand how bad mitch mcconnell
is and gosh these stupid people in
kentucky that's not what it is
i mean for my book i went to every
county in kentucky we have 120 which is
too many but we have 120
and i went to every one and finding a
true mitch mcconnell supporter is almost
impossible
nobody likes the guy and nobody likes
him for the exact reason you said
they don't feel like he cares about
kentucky they feel like he's a dc
person but here's the problem we've
never as democrats given them somebody
who people believe cares more than mitch
in kentucky and i think in a lot of red
states if you have a
run-of-the-mill republican and a running
mill democrat
people are going to vote for the
republican they just are so you have to
do something different and you have to
say
i am different than them in a way that
connects and the problem for the
democratic party in my opinion
in middle america especially is that we
connect culturally but we don't connect
economically
and in places where the culture is not
the same as a lot of the mainstream
parts of the democratic party they just
have no connection to the democratic
party
so we have stopped talking about blue
collar issues or we don't do it enough
and that is how you used to win in
kentucky democrats used to run this
state forever
and they talked about blue collar this
is a working-class state this used to be
a big union state
and when does the last time you've heard
a democrat talk about unions i mean
don't talk about unions they don't
ever and they coal mining unions were
huge here steel unions like they
look you know this was a union place and
people just don't ever bring it up
and thus since the culture wars become a
lot of national politics it hurts in
places like here and that is why mitch
mcconnell
who is deeply unliked who workers
believe doesn't care about them at all
when it becomes a culture war battle
they end up choosing his side
your point about how democrats have lost
on the economic messaging
uh and for blue-collar workers
union households i experienced the same
thing on the trail and
one of the things that they're seeing
right now between joe
and trump is that a lot of the union
leaders are endorsing joe and kamala
because you still have like a democratic
relationship there
but a lot of the rank and file members
are voting for trump and that
happened at a very high level
in 2016 where like the majority of these
union households went to trump no matter
what their leaders said
and that's going to keep happening if
we're not careful i think the difference
in my opinion the reason in michigan
pennsylvania and wisconsin biden is
doing
a little better than clinton is that
that kind of rank and file union like
joe a little bit better than they like
hillary and he talked a little bit more
about this stuff but that's where we're
losing you know i speak to union groups
all the time and what my message is
welcome
in those in those places but they don't
hear democrat
politicians talking about that certainly
on the national level now on the state
level we have a democratic governor
again andy beshear
and a big part of that was because he
spoke to teachers unions
and and that was a big part of him
getting elected
i think we've lost that message and part
of the reason i really liked you
i ended up endorsing you which i had no
intention of doing when i saw you
thank you appreciate it yeah thank you
and you got up and said so you got up
and told so i took my radio show to iowa
it's a sports radio show but i wanted to
do something to get different so i took
them to the iowa caucuses
and we saw every candidate speak and the
three guys who do the show with me don't
even care about politics
and i was interested to see what happens
at the end of this
who will they be for and everyone on our
show was for you at the end
and the reason was when we saw you speak
you talked about the economic
impact on small towns we saw you in a
place called perry iowa
and you got up and said look no one
speaks about economics in small towns
and you're right
republicans don't now they'll speak
about culture and social issues but they
don't talk about the economics because
it's their economic policy that's
killing small
towns and democrats act like those
places don't even exist
and when you you spoke about it and
you're right america
is full of small towns and most people
live in cities started in small towns
and we're just abandoning them
abandoning them and then and i don't
know
unless we figure that out we're gonna
have a place
where you know there's gonna be vast
swaths of land where people are just
isolated from the economy and you know
dollar general stores started in
kentucky and i wrote about this in mitch
please
how they go into small towns and
basically ruin the communities they
close all the local stores
they create the only place people shop
and the next thing you know
all the money gets shipped out that's
what i worry about across the united
states
that's a hundred percent happening right
now and you can see
dollar general and walmart came and ran
over the mom and pops
uh and then now amazon's like a
spaceship that's like sucking up
what whatever is left uh and if you are
in the small town it's not just that
you're isolated
like when your way of life starts to
degrade then terrible things start
happening you look around like you know
you have
people who are still living there and as
the opportunities dry up
um you have people drink more people
um end up with domestic
violence and other problems at higher
levels or they never marry they they
never
find a partner because getting married
having a child they're very optimistic
acts like you you you need a degree of
stability if you're going to get
together with someone and say hey
let's get married let's start a family
let's do all the stuff um
and you start kicking out the paths
forward for a lot of people
you see families deteriorate very
quickly or never form
i'm with you that this is the disconnect
for the democratic party
like the democratic party needs to not
content itself with being
uh the party of the urban core
or of cultural issues uh there was part
of me matt when i was running
i was like is there some kind of strange
agenda where people
prefer it if we talk about these
cultural issues
over the the uh bread and butter the
dollars and cents because they're just
making a lot of money off of us and they
just want to
pit us against each other on this
[ __ ] and they're laughing all the
way to the bank
i mean if you were to go on fox news or
msnbc and try to argue about tax policy
you know i mean who nobody's going to
care but it is what's most important i
mean
so i live in kentucky people still like
trump here at least a lot of people do
and i will talk to them they'll say why
don't you like him and and there are
a million reasons but the thing that
bothers me the most were his tax cuts
he basically enacted mitch mcconnell's
tax policy
which has a hugely detrimental impact on
the poor
and the middle class vis-a-vis the
wealthy and people just
and it happened and everybody got
excited because they got you know a
check in the mail for
for one time and it it infuriates me
because
whatever you want to say about trump and
there's a lot to say when he ran
one thing he did i will give him credit
for is he looked at these people
in blue collar small towns and he said
you know what your lives are important
your problems exist and i'm going to
help
him now he hasn't helped him and he's
full of it he doesn't care about him
but at least he acknowledged them and we
in the democratic party
do not acknowledge them way too often i
don't think it's out of maliciousness
i just don't think there are very many
democrats who know about places like
this i mean there are not too many
shared browns there just aren't too many
of those people
left that are winning elections and so
you don't hear
voices like mine when's the last time
you heard outside of james carville
a southern twang representing the
democratic party
i don't know i mean it just does not
happen and i think that leads to a lot
of people
you know colin powell said many years
ago about african americans until they
can
see people represented that look like
them in the republican party they're not
going to join it
and he was right well what's happening
is in small towns they're not seeing
people like them
representing the democratic party and
it's turning them off
and i'm living proof that if you speak
to folks they will listen because no
one's going to mistake me for
like like someone um you know who i mean
maybe they would
like i'd appreciate it you have
you come off as someone who genuinely
cares and most importantly you don't
come off as someone
who thinks they're better a lot of this
is in places like kentucky we are
worried that you and the rest of the
country look down at us
we are worried that you think we're
stupid that you think we don't
know how to do anything and when someone
talks to us like that
we turn them off they're done forget it
and i'm not gonna call out the
politicians that do that but there are a
lot to do
you don't do that i don't think joe
biden does that and i actually think
that's why
you've seen him do better than some
other candidates
is simply that notice when the
democratic primaries got to the states
that are like that joe won in a
heartbeat and i think you would have had
success for that same reason you're the
only two candidates in the election that
i genuinely thought
spoke to people in places like this in a
way they could connect
thank you for listening in i hope you
enjoyed this conversation if you did
please do subscribe to yang speaks and
click on notifications so we can let you
know
every time we have a new episode
you